الهدوء الذي يسود الجولان المحتل والشقه
السوريي للجبهه الشماليه عاده خادعا فليس
بعيدا تدور ما تسميها اسرائيل بالمعركه
بين الحروب بينها وبين ايران حيث تستهدف
اسرائيل ما تقول انه مواقع ايرانيه او
شحنات اسلحه دقيقه واستراتيجيه معدل حزب
الله معركه سريه القاعده فيها عدم
الاعتراف بالغارات منعا لاحراج الطرف
الاخر وجره للرد لهذا فان يتبني رئيس
الاركان الاسرائيلي لهجوم دير الزور كان
لافتا يخل الولد
عن القافله السوريه المتجهه من العراق الى
سوريا وكان من الممكن ان لا نعرف ما كان
فيها وان لا نعرف ايضا انه من بين 25
شاحنه فان الشاحنه رقم ثمانيه هي الشاحنه
التي تقل الوسائل القتاليه
ورغم تصريحات كوخابي ايضا بان اسرائيل
عرقله التموضع الايراني خاصه نشر صواريخ
ارجو في سوريا ولبنان ومحاوله انشاء حزب
الله سوري على تخوم الجولان فان الغارات
لا تتوقف وقد تتكثف لخشيه اسرائيل من ان
تستغل ايران تعاونها مع روسيا في الحرب
على اوكرانيا لتعميق طموضوعها في سوريا
حيث نشرت بطاريات دفاع جوي في محيط دمشق
بمثابه رسائل تحضيريه ربما
الصحه
اليوم التي تاتي على خلفيه الانباء حول
احتمال استخدام مطار بيروت لنقل الاسلحه
اللي حزب الله هذا الامر يخلق اسرائيل
سوريا تشكل عمليا ساحه المواجهه المباشره
بين اسرائيل وايران حيث باتت الجبهه
الشماليه موحده بين سوريا ولبنان
ما تسميها اسرائيل بالمعركه بين الحروب
والتي تشمل سوريا ولبنان والعراق ودول
اخرى هي حرب ظلال تهدف اسرائيليا الى مرعي
ايران من اقامه جبهه قتاليه لاستخدامها في
الحرب المقبله ويحاطه اسرائيل باسلحه
استراتيجيه او دقيقه زياد حلب بالعربيه
القدس الغربيه